Alright.
I'm gonna figure this out right now.
Okay, step 1: Physical contact.
Do they ever touch or hit you?
Yes!
That's a thing she does like a lot.
Usually, when I've said something hilarious, which is all the time.
But, I've seen her doing it to other people like this one time with this guy Jonathan.
Okay, that doesn't prove anything.
2. Acting Differently.
Well, how do I know what she's like when I'm not around if I'm never there to see it?
Oh, there's this one thing.
When I say something unexpectedly hilarious,...
...she seems to purposely not laugh and kind of avoids looking at me.
That's something, right?
Number 3: Familiarity.
Do they share personal information with you?
Do they trust you with secrets?
Yeah!
She tells me weird secrets all the time.
Sometimes, I don't even know why she tells me them but she does.
This is looking good.
Okay, number 4: Body Language.
Sometimes, she ignores me altogether.
Moving on, number 5: Special Attention.
Do they take interest in your interests?
Oh, this one time she got me my favorite kind of candy.
I mean, this isn't any kind of candy either.
You have to go to a specific part of the city to get it because...
...they don't even make this kind of candy in America.
That has to mean she likes me a little bit, right?
And if she likes me a little, it's enough to ask her if she could like me a lot.
Or I could be wrong and I could ruin a perfectly good friendship...
...and regret it forever.